[Música]
boa tarde
educação é a arma mais poderosa que você
tem nas mãos para transformar uma nação
é através da educação que a filha de um
mineiro pode se tornar a história da
mina mas é também através da educação
que o filho de um camponês se torna em
presidente de uma grande nação
isto mesmo foi dito pura nelson mandela
um dos ícones mundiais de liderança
eu ouço essas palavras meu nome é luis
mex a manga já foi apresentado eu vim de
angola nas se numa pequena aldeia de
nome vila graça pela graça está inserida
muitas vezes eu digo está perdida nos
arredores de uma cidade chamada o ambu e
o hamburgo é parte do planalto de angola
na vila graça eu me lembro de algumas
coisas coisas que eu quero partilhar com
vocês lembram das privações
privações de vária ordem
as privações de segurança por exemplo
uma das coisas que eu mais me lembro
sendo que na época quando era miúdo
quando era menino e enquanto essas
privações estudavam estava em pleno uma
guerra civil
no meu país a guerra civil como vocês
podem calcular
ela nos priva de segurança ela nos tira
a vontade é uma dessas privações que eu
experimentei ao longo da minha infância
mas eu lembro mais de outras privações
uma dessas privações que não deixa de
ser importante a privação de nutriente
de alimento privação de comida
vocês também devem saber que quando
acontece uma guerra
a logística é a primeira a ser destruída
as condições de transportação as pontes
nas estradas os aeroportos são os
primeiros a serem destruídos para que
não haja remaster cimento mas é hoje no
humor mais na vila graça é hoje moro
numa cidade ao lado numa cidade vizinha
da cidade do huambo
e esta cidade onde eu moro tem o nome de
cuito
minha família e eu nos mudamos para o
quito no ano de 2012 a cidade do kuito
não é muito semelhante na cidade do
huambo a cidade do kuito é diferente a
cidade do kuito é mais pequena do que a
cidade do huambo
ela é pequena a tal ponto de que a sua
população não passa de 200 mil
habitantes a sua urba como município ela
poderá ter perto de 400 mil habitantes
mas como urbano como centro da cidade
não passa de 200 mil habitantes desta
pequena cidade
ela foi cotada como uma das cidades mais
destruídas durante o mesmo conflito de
que eu fiz menção assinada em que se
você tiver sido nela em 2009 ou no
caminho
antes você ficaria aterrorizado cotada
como uma das que mais foi destruída pela
guerra não é tudo
é consenso também em angola de que
aquela região a região do bié a região
das que mais foi me nada estou a falar
de minas terrestres estou a falar de
minas soais antipessoais minas anti
tanque
ela é também cotada como está a cidade
esta cidade e esta região das que mais
me nada foi por causa disso o wings ou a
quantidade de pessoas diminuídos
fisicamente é muito grande e vocês devem
também calcular que a quantidade de
pessoas traumatizadas emocionalmente
também deve ser muito grande mas é
exatamente ali nesta cidade
é ali onde eu e minha família estamos
estamos a empreender no setor de
educação
eu não estudei a educação não tem uma
graduação em pedagogia não tem uma
pós-graduação em didática e não tem um
mestrado nesta área do saber
eu por acaso estudei a administração
estuda negócios estudei liderança e por
que que eu faço educação aqui algumas
razões muito interessantes as quais eu
gostava de partilhar para que vocês
pudessem perceber a razão porque eu
estou nesta ramo a minha mãe que é
considerada heroína da minha vida
ela não falou muito pra mim e por isso
as mães que estão aqui
seria bom que falassem muito para seus
filhos ela não falou muito para mim
uma das coisas que ela mais fez comigo
foi me dar comandos
vem cá pega isso leva para lá ir lá vai
outro lado siga faça isso é o que eu
mais me lembro que minha mãe fez mas no
meio disto tudo ela por três vezes disse
algo que ficou marcado em mim ela disse
nascimento
o filho se tu queres que estas coisas
que nós estamos a viver mudem estuda
numa outra ocasião ela voltou a falar
falou exatamente a mesma coisa com
palavras diferentes mas ela falou o
capitão é a mensagem na segunda vez
surgiu uma terceira vez em que ela
voltou a falar ao ter voltado a falar na
terceira vez
eu segurei esse recado como se fosse uma
ordem mas por outro lado o escritor que
jovens ano
eu disse que cada um de nós tem de
encontrar o seu elemento em 1996 eu
acredito ter encontrado o meu elemento
não só na junção das palavras da minha
mãe
nas três vezes em que ela falou pra mim
mas provavelmente por aquilo que eu fui
vendo ao longo do tempo da minha
vivência e do meu crescimento
eu senti claramente por convicção de que
a área da minha influência é educação
apesar de não ter estudado educação eu
sinto o chamado específico para
influenciar a sociedade através de
educação mas porque também através da
educação através do saber
eu fiz alguns negócios vizinhos que
foram interessantes na época das grandes
cas eses em algum momento eu ia ajudar
alguns colegas a fazer provas em
contrapartida sabe que recebia comida
davam comida que esta era minha maior
necessidade era feliz em receber comida
em troca de algum conhecimento
então dá bons negócios não dá disse que
também é um fator que faz com que a
educação não seja menosprezada
mas em último lugar
nelson mandela eu já fiz citação no
início é o disk educação é a arma mais
poderosa que você tem nas mãos para
alterar a realidade de uma nação
e ele diz que se a filha de um mineiro é
capaz de se tornar gestora dessa mina e
o filho de um camponês é capaz de se
tornar presidente de uma grande nação eu
segurei este recado eu disse à educação
fazer em 2014 recrutei três jovens ea
idéia era fazer surgir uma iniciativa
educativa uma iniciativa que eu possa a
ser diferente foi marcar a diferença
dois jovens para ensinar inglês e uma
jovem para cuidar das questões
administrativas e começamos foi montado
um pequeno programa de ensino de língua
inglesa nas férias e tivemos um punhado
de alunos
eles vieram juntar nossa nós seguramos
uma infraestrutura que estava meio que
abandonada
fizemos um negócio com o senhorio da
infraestrutura e tivemos a
infraestrutura e começamos a trabalhar
não demorou muito tempo vamos agregar
outros valores
tornamos nosso programa de inglês de
férias rapidamente para um programa de
inglês regular
agregamos educação pré escolar
introduzimos dentro do nosso programa
reforço escolar para alunos que estudam
em outras escolas estudando em outras
escolas eles não têm o suficiente para
se tornarem capazes de responder às
exigências da ciência e da vida
introduzimos isso no nosso programa e
introduzimos uma escola do ensino
primário foi foi excelente
foi interessante ver este começo eu sou
daqueles que estando neste lugar
desconhecido
neste lugar pequeno neste lugar que se
você chegar a angola e você perguntar
quais são as cidades cotadas desse país
você não vai ouvir na cidade do kuito
você provavelmente vai ouvir luanda que
é a capital naturalmente você vai ouvir
lubango que é a segunda cidade mais
populosa vai ouvir mãe dela que é
terceira vai ouvir o ambu que por sinal
nem se pular etapas de ouvir cabinda
também você não vai ouvir com 88 esta
pequenez que sonha grande e eu quero vos
convidar a acreditarem na grandeza do
a acreditarem na complexidade do simples
e acreditarem na força do fraco é
exatamente a partir daqui desta cidade
do kuito em que a iniciativa grupo
educacional chamanga foi surgindo e foi
se tornando algo que é capaz de fazer
alguma coisa
o grande objetivo era trazer esta
iniciativa que possa ser o catalisador
para empoderar essa geração de crianças
e adolescentes a se tornarem líderes mas
líderes que vão liderar com base na
dignidade humana
já tá lera a indignado com a qual eu fiz
a minha educação eu estava inconformado
mas surgiu algo pequeno que sonha
grandes o tamanho foi se alargando hoje
nós estamos a comemorar cinco anos
começamos com estes três jovens mazel
fizemos uma equipe de quatro mas hoje
hoje nós temos a alegria de celebrar
algumas coisas aqui coisas interessantes
hoje celebramos o facto de que já não
acham simplesmente quatro pessoas a
trabalhar mas hoje nós temos mais do que
55 jovens a levar a cabo esta actividade
de empoderar essa geração
hoje mais do que 400 crianças se
espalham pelas facilidades do grupo
educacional se a manga
hoje nós celebramos o fato também de que
mais do que 30 pessoas e destas 30
pessoas
eu tenho um prazer de dizer que boa
parte deles são crianças e adolescentes
eles são capazes de falar a língua
inglesa fluentemente como se tivessem
ido para inglaterra e como se tivesse
ido para qualquer um outro país de
língua inglesa mas não foram eles
aprenderam lá na cidade do kuito
lá dentro da academia de línguas
chamanga
e é isso no fundo que faz acreditar que
a distância que vai entre o sonho ea
realização é ação
hoje nós também celebramos mais nos
celebramos hoje relacionamentos
institucionais muito fortes
a razão por que estou aqui hoje eu estou
neste palco eu estou nesta tese da
unievangélica
é por causa deste avanço diplomático
científico alguma coisa que começou há
cinco anos atrás como uma pequenez que
sonha com uma grandeza eu hoje estou
aqui estou aqui para expandir esta
iniciativa
nós montamos uma parceria com esta
instituição
temos uma outra parceria com uma
instituição de ensino superior
localizada em varginha
o grupo educacional o lixo temos uma
aproximação muito forte com instituições
de ensino fora do meu país e dentro do
meu país gostava de destacar aqui o a
venda do kit nacional ficou temos uma
aproximação muito forte temos uma
aproximação muito forte com a rádio
triste disco em pretória na áfrica do
sul
isto nos faz celebrar aquilo que nós
sempre sonhamos
hoje nós levamos os nossos alunos para
fazer intercâmbio de língua e de cultura
em países anglófonos os levamos para a
namíbia os levamos para a áfrica do sul
os levamos para a inglaterra
e isto é por causa da força da pequenez
isso é por causa da crença de que
cedemos um passo o que nós sempre
sonhamos é capaz de ser realizado
mas por que eu ainda estou lá porque que
ainda eu estou com essa histamina o que
é que me movem e que também move o mundo
nós temos sonhos esta escola
essa escola surgiu para recuperar a
estima de um povo que está cotado de
forma bastante negativa no concerto das
nações
isto é algo que pra mim mudança bastante
inconformado qual é a luta a luta a luta
tem de ser a luta da inteligência
a luta tem de ser da competência e esta
escola surgiu para isso nossa missão é
empoderar essa geração dos jovens para
que se tornem lindas que vão liberar com
base na dignidade humana
o nosso sonho e é nos tornar a escola
mais influente do nosso país
tô aqui com algumas cautelas na verdade
eu quero dizer o nosso sonho se tornar a
melhor escola de angola isso que eu
quero dizer nós sonhamos produzir os
presidentes e os ministros do nosso país
mas vamos mais nós sonhamos em produzir
aquele os funcionários da auto nível das
organizações internacionais pensem no
banco mundial pensei num secretário
geral das nações unidas
pensem num presidente do comitê olímpico
internacional e vocês podem levar gols
pensamento em várias outras organizações
nós queremos com esta ousadia e pelo
caminho da educação conquistar aquilo
que nós nunca tínhamos conquistado e
queremos aumentar e transformar a forma
como longe somos cotados
neste concerto das nações mas nós
gostaríamos que a nossa pequena cidade e
por causa da educação
a nossa pequena cidade fosse se
transformar no centro do desenvolvimento
sustentável
nós pretendemos mesmo e de forma muito
mais ousada em série o modelo nacional
para investigação científica do nosso
país
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]